News is heating up about 5g the
ultra-fast wireless technology that has
the potential to connect everything from
smartphones to self-driving cars to
virtual worlds the race to 5g is moving
forward at full speed AT&T Sprint and
t-mobile all say that 5g technology is
at the heart of their new corporate
strategies it will allow us to do all
kinds of stuff like streaming your
favorite videos up to 100 times faster
but the fifth generation of wireless
connectivity has spurred a lot of rumors
about its potential some of which are
less than accurate we're going to
separate fact from fiction and walk you
through five of the biggest myths about
five G while 5g networks are expected to
be up to 100 times faster than current
4G networks it doesn't end there 5g is
being marketed as a platform that will
enhance the user experience of many
different technologies and devices take
this 5g robot on display at the 2019 MWC
tradeshow in Barcelona it can serve you
a coffee
the current 4G network just isn't nimble
enough to operate a machine like this so
the robot itself is now an avatar it
connects to the cloud over mobile
network in addition to serving coffee
behive G is expected to make it possible
to automate more manufacturing by
improving the efficiency of machines and
allowing humans to work alongside them
with augmented reality headsets
what makes 5g unique isn't the amount of
data it can send at a given time but
rather its low latency connections
bandwidth measures the amount of data
that can be transferred at a given time
latency measures the speed of
communication between two points 5g
promises low latency connections which
could be a game-changer in a range of
industries for example analysts think
the data could travel almost instantly
maybe even fast enough to mimic human
reflexes which could help doctors
perform remote medical procedures
Verizon's 5g ultra-wideband Network aims
to do just that low latency is crucial
for things like surgery because the
response time has to be immediate it has
to be real while the technology hasn't
been widely deployed yet the idea is
that 5g would allow a physical therapist
to help a patient recover their range of
motion after surgery or allow students
at research hospitals to watch remote
surgeries in near real-time the low
latency also helps increase
point-to-point communication for
driverless cars as seen with this
self-driving bus that was on display at
South Korea's 2018 Olympic Games 5g
connections will allow automakers to
transmit large amounts of data at speeds
far faster than the current generation
cellular service which could allow
vehicles to talk directly with each
other on the road like 4G 5g is set to
kickstart a wide range of innovation in
the mobile field but it's also making
inroads into many different industries
including entertainment construction and
even farming agricultural manufacturer
John Deere hopes to use 5g technology on
its farms as it could allow equipment
like tractors to communicate with other
machines on the field much faster the
company said 5g could allow a skilled
operator to run multiple machines
simultaneously and facilitate real-time
data capture and decision-making over
time
5g could theoretically replace 4G but
that's at least decades away
that's because 5g requires new
infrastructure clusters of antennas that
are closer to the users this will likely
take years to install across the country
and while most of the major cell
carriers have already started to roll
out 5g they've only started installing
it in some major cities meaning 4G isn't
going anywhere
in the near future
this brings us to our final myth that 5g
is coming soon this is only true for
people in certain areas of some vague
cities in the u.s. one of the first
countries with 5g services many of the
major cell carriers including Verizon
AT&T and t-mobile have announced plans
for nationwide 5g coverage we're
planning for a 5g future that covers you
from coast to coast and everywhere in
between but so far these carriers have
only deployed 5g in large cities with
high population densities t-mobile
customers for example can expect 5g
access in at least five cities including
Dallas Las Vegas Los Angeles and New
York by the end of 2019
but since providers are focusing first
on bigger cities the launch of 5g
services could take many years to reach
rural areas across the country and many
rural areas in the US have yet to even
adopt 4G meaning a nationwide deployment
of 5g technologies could be a long way
away